foreign
in this brief presentation I'll discuss
a recent book that I had they come out
published named the Extraterrestrial
that you can see in the middle of the
first slide here
um and if I had to summarize it I would
say when you are not ready to find
exceptional things you will never
discover them this was the subject of a
Scientific American commentary that I
wrote last year
what you see on the right side is a
textbook a thousand pages long that will
be published in a month or so by Harvard
University press uh and that would serve
the scientific Community searching for
either microbial life or intelligent
life out there beyond Earth
and what you see on the left is a
photograph of a picture that was hung on
the walls of the Berlin Brandenburg
Academy of Science and Humanities uh it
was taken by the German photographer her
Linda quilbell that came to my office
and asked me to write on the palm of my
hand
uh the most important scientific
question that I can think of and I wrote
are we alone and after working for
several decades uh in astronomy uh the
the most important lesson that I've
learned is a sense of modesty and over
the past few years both my parents
passed away so let me explain uh how I
arrived more recently at this
perspective by reading a couple of
paragraphs from my book
My Father David was laid to rest in the
same red soil in which he planted trees
all his life in the vicinity of those
plantations that he watered routinely
near the house that he built with his
rugged hands and that I grew up in
surrounded by the people he loved and
who loved him in return under the blue
sky that I study as an astronomer
my mother Sarah who put me on the road
to thinking as a philosopher with whom I
spoke daily throughout my adulthood and
who especially gifted me with a life of
the Mind was buried beside him
two years later
in astronomy we realized that matter
takes new forms over time
the matter we are made of was made in
the hearts of massive stars that
exploded
it assembled to make the Earth that
nourishes plants that feed our bodies
what are we then if not just flitting
shapes taken by a few specks of material
for a brief moment in Cosmic history on
the surface of one planet out of so many
we are insignificant not just because
the cosmos is so vast but also because
we ourselves are so tiny
each of us is merely a transient
structure that comes and goes
recorded in the minds of other transient
structures
and that is all
so there is no Escape
if you look at the Universe At Large
from a sense of modesty
because we are born into this world just
like actors put on a stage and the first
thing you notice
is the stage is huge it's 10 to the
power 26 times larger than our body
and we have no idea what the play is
about but one thing we know is that the
play has been going on for 13.8 billion
years and we just came at the end so
clearly this play is not about us
but nevertheless people tend to think
that the world centers on them
the ancient Greek philosopher Aristotle
argued that and people believed him for
a thousand years because it flattered
their ego
and when you look at the picture like
this of a king that conquered a piece of
land on Earth and felt very uh proud of
himself
uh you you
are surprised given the big scheme of
things
um because about half of all the
sun-like Stars host the planet the size
of the Earth roughly the same separation
we know it from the latest data that
came from the Kepler satellite
and so there are more habitable Earths
in the observable volume of the universe
than there are grains of sand on all
beaches on Earth
and so this King
is not more impressive than an ant that
hugs a single grain of sand on the
landscape of a huge beach
that is
not impressive at all
but I can understand where it's coming
from that sense of self-importance uh
because when my two daughters were young
and they were at home they tended to
think the world centers on them
and that they are the smartest
but then when they went to the
kindergarten they met other kids they
got and got a different perspective
and of course if I were to ask them on
their first day
um whether they would prefer to be at
home or go to the kindergarten they
would much rather be at home and
maintain their illusion that they are at
the center of the world so in a way our
civilization
is following their footsteps
and the only way for us to mature as a
civilization is to meet others
and I'm pretty convinced that when we do
we will realize that we are not the
sharpest cookies in the jar and by the
jar I mean the Milky Way galaxy
and that's based on the news that I read
every morning
um it's quite obvious that we are not
acting intelligently we are fighting
each other trying to feel Superior
relative to each other
instead of cooperating towards a better
future which is the intelligent thing to
do earth is our home
but only for a while there are internal
threats from changing the climate of the
planet
Wars pandemics and other catastrophes
but there are also external threats from
the impact of an asteroid or eventually
in a billionaires the sun will boil off
all oceans on Earth
so we need to go to space spread our
eggs in more than one basket
and let me just say a few words about my
journey from a farm I was born on a farm
in Israel to space
and so
I was born 59 years ago you can see a
picture of me in my childhood there on
the top left
uh I used to collect eggs every
afternoon we had chicken and you can see
that in the second image from the left I
used to drive a tractor
um to the hills of the village and on
weekends and read philosophy books
because
philosophy addresses the most
fundamental questions we have and
um I was passionate about him but then
circumstances led me to pursue physics
and astrophysics and I ended up as chair
of the astronomy department at Harvard
for the past decade
uh in May 2015 a black limousine
parked in front of the center for
astrophysics at Harvard and out of it
came an entrepreneur from Silicon Valley
named the Yuri Milner
he came to my office sat on the sofa in
front of me and asked me whether I'm
willing to lead a project to visit the
nearest star during his lifetime
and I knew that the nearest star is four
light years away it takes four years for
light to Traverse the distance and
therefore
if you want to get there within 20 years
you need a spacecraft that moves at the
fifth of the speed of light
and that's a thousand times faster than
the chemical rockets that we have been
using so far
sort of like the jump from the first car
that Henry Ford invented and spacecraft
that's the jumping speed that we need
and so I told Yuri I need to think about
it and then I recommended after six
months
a method of doing that based on
discussions within my research group
so here is a diagram of the solar system
you can see the sun on the left
and then the planets and at 100 times
the Earth's sun separation uh that's
where the planets more or less
end
and that's also the place where the
solar wind is stopped by the gas that
fills in the voids between Stars the
interstellar medium but that's not where
the solar system ends that's where
Voyager 1 and 2 are roughly at but the
solar system extends a thousand times
farther
um into a volume called the the art
cloud which is basically a collection of
the bricks that were left over from the
construction project of the solar system
so these are just rocks uh that were
thrown out during the build up of the
planets
and the old cloud is about halfway to
the nearest star
the Alpha Centauri system has three
stars the nearest is Proxima Centauri
and if each star has an old Cloud they
are touching each other just like
densely packed billiard balls
and when one star moves relative to
another it can dislodge some of these
rocks into Interstellar space
so this is an artist's illustration of
Proxima Centauri it's a dwarf star 12
the mass of the Sun and emits mostly
infrared light because it has half the
temperature of the Sun the surface
temperature
uh and the planet there is a planet next
to it which happens to be just at the
right distance to potentially have
liquid water on its surface it's 20
times closer to the stud than the Earth
is from the Sun and because of that it's
tidally locked it has a permanent day
side that faces the star at all times in
a permanent night side
and my daughters say that if we ever go
there they would like to have a house on
the Strip that separates these two sides
where you can see the sunset forever
just imagine sitting on the porch and
seeing the sunset the sun would never
set basically just on the horizon at all
times
uh and since this star emits infrared
light if there are any creatures on the
planet
uh they should have infrared eyes and I
asked students in my class A few weeks
ago if they know of any creature on
Earth that has eyes sensitive to the
infrared and one of them found this
shrimp
that does look like an alien to me
so how do we get there and that's the
method I recommended to Yuri Miller and
the project is called the star shot we
announced it publicly in the company of
Stephen Hawking in 2016.
uh basically the idea is to have a very
thin uh
uh layer of material sort of like a sale
on a boat except not being pushed by the
wind but being pushed by reflecting
light we call it a light Sail
and if you shine a very powerful laser
of about 100 gigawatt for a few minutes
on a sale that weighs about a gram and
is roughly the size of a person then you
get to a fifth of the speed of light
across the distance of
um five times the distance to the Moon
and one can equip this sale with
electronics including a navigation
device communication device and a camera
and here is an artist the illustration
of that concept A sale is being released
above the atmosphere so that it won't
encounter the friction and then a very
powerful laser beam is produced by the
by collection an array of low power
lasers that combine together
to push it for a few minutes
to a fifth of the speed of light
and then after these first few minutes
it sails for 20 years towards Proxima
Centauri and one can release a sale
every day most of the cost is in the
laser array
and of course the journey is very long
and quite boring but eventually when the
sale gets there it could take a
photograph of the planet next to Proxima
Centauri and send the photograph back to
us it will take another four years for
that signal to reach us
but it could inform us whether the
planet has life on it
and the signal would be very faint so we
would need of course a very powerful
telescope to detect it
after 24 years since the launch
so this is the concept of star shot and
of course one can imagine other targets
not just Proxima Centauri and we are
currently working on developing the
technology
but it's not just the question of
whether there is life the most
fundamental question is are we the
smartest kids
on the Block
and frankly I don't think so because if
you look at recipe books you see that
out of the same ingredients you can make
very different cakes and so what is the
chance that out of the chemicals that
existed on early Earth we got through
random processes the best cake
imaginable
but instead of arguing about it we can
just search that is the best approach to
figure out the answer and the best place
for us to look is in our backyard
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas